looks like Chick-fil-A will not be
opening any new restaurants in Uganda
anytime soon the longtime favorite
company of conservatives has apparently
embraced the Dei agenda
according to a heretofore unnoticed
diversity equity and inclusion segment
of Chick-fil-A's website quote one of
our core values at Chick-fil-A
Incorporated is that we are better
together when we combine our unique
backgrounds blah blah blah with a
culture of belonging we can discover new
ways to blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah the exact verbiage does not exactly
matter it's all
pretty much just gobbledygook anyway
the disconcerting thing
is not the exact wording the
disconcerting thing is that Chick-fil-A
has embraced Dei at all and now while
some conservatives are calling for a
boycott of the openly religious
generally relatively conservative
company as far as I'm concerned this
story has almost nothing to do with
Chick-fil-A
the Chick-fil-A
Dei Department
doesn't tell you a ton about the chicken
shop it tells you about the depth and
pervasiveness of a liberal ideology
throughout our entire culture
it isn't just Disney
it isn't just Target it isn't just
transheiser bush
even
Chick-fil-A
is subject to increasingly radical
liberalism and we will not merely buy
another sandwich to fix it the only way
to fix it is by resetting reorienting
our entire political order even
Chick-fil-A right now go to puretalk.com
Knowles
we're all trying to improve the country
here aren't we and therefore we've got
to be a little bit Discerning about the
partners that we choose to work with in
one company I'm very very proud to stand
behind and a company that's very proud
to stand behind us and our country is
pure talk veteran owned with a 100
American Workforce they share our
beliefs our desires for this country
that is why Pure Talk is the official
cell phone wireless partner of the daily
wire but that's not the only reason Pure
Talk also happens to be the most
Dependable 5G Network in the United
States they've got a top tier service at
a fraction of the cost of those other
woke companies you know the ones I'm
talking about ATT Verizon T-Mobile those
companies that don't care about you or
your values in fact you can get
unlimited talk text and unlimited data
with a mobile hotspot for just 55 a
month you vote with how you spend your
money so stop supporting woke wireless
companies that don't support you instead
go to puretalk.com Knowles you will get
great coverage and save while you're
doing it go to puretalk.com Knowles save
an additional fifty five zero percent
off your first month because they
actually care about you go to
puretalk.com Knowles puretalk Wireless
for Americans by Americans right now go
to balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles living a healthy lifestyle is
not always easy especially when you are
on the go you need simple manageable
routines to make sure you are getting
the proper nutrition every single day
that's why I'm a huge fan of balance of
nature balance of nature fruits and
veggies are a great way to ensure that
you're getting essential nutritional
ingredients every day their capsules are
packed with 100 whole food that you can
take at any time balance of nature uses
a cold vacuum process that preserves the
natural phytonutrients in whole fruits
and vegetables and encapsulates them for
easy consumption balance of nature sent
a bunch of their products down to the
studio for us to try and these absolute
jackals around here just gobbled them up
we had to claw over each other to try to
get them from these hyenas so make sure
that you get your own balance of nature
right now go to balanceofnature.com use
promo code Knolls Canada wles for 35 off
your first order as a preferred customer
that is
balanceofnature.com promo code Knowles
kwles for 35 percent off your first
preferred order Jane Fonda says we need
to imprison white men
uh Jane Fonda of Hanoi Jane Fame she's
the lady who allowed the
Vietnamese Communists to sit her down on
an anti-aircraft gun and make like she
was shooting down American uh flyers and
attacking American troops she later
apologized for that but then she
remained a huge anti-American lib so the
content of that apology is somewhat
dubious Jane Fonda just said quote
it's good for us all to realize there
would be no climate crisis if there was
no racism
there would be no climate crisis if
there was no patriarchy
a mindset that sees everything in a
hierarchical way white men are the
things that matter and then everything
else is at the bottom that's the problem
this mindset that sees things in a
hierarchical way by the way white men
are the absolute worst
I love She's attacking this hierarchical
white male way of thinking and how does
she do it she arranges it in a hierarchy
of evil people at the very top of the
hierarchy of evilness at the very bottom
of the hierarchy of goodness she puts
the white men okay she says that poor
people of color
as well as people in the southern
hemisphere will be hit hardest by global
warming she says it's a tragedy that we
have to absolutely stop we have to
arrest and jail those men they're all
men
okay all those white men we've got to
throw them in jail because they're
pushing global warming
maybe worth pointing out to Hanoi Jane
that as far as Nations go
the biggest contributor to global
warming such as it is is a China
uh China which famously does not have a
lot of white men running it
but regardless yeah sure America we're a
big industrial country we're the leader
of the Free World and so there are still
and good number of white men in America
and okay
that's the problem the climate crisis
would not exist if that not for
patriarchy the climate crisis would not
exist for racism the climate crisis is
the fault of white men of course it is
it has to be
and climate change catastrophic climate
change we're just nine years away from
the end of the world as they've been
telling us for 50 years uh
that also
requires white men to be the fault of it
because
white people just equals bad
climate change equals
secular apocalypse
and so yes evil
will bring about the end of the world
and in the Christian understanding of
the Apocalypse things get really really
really bad as Sin and death and evil
pervade all the world and the prince of
this world leads to all sorts of
terrible things you know the devil the
father of Lies but then there's a happy
ending there is a happy ending here
because Christ wins the war and comes
down and you have the final judgment in
the secular version of this now we just
all turn to worm food evil in the
secular version in the leftist version
evil just wins
and this shapes the way that we view the
world
this is education Hanoi Jane's comments
here
Fatima Muhammad's comments at CUNY law
school the dude in the dress at
Disneyland all of this stuff
the Latino white supremacy this
constitutes education a lot more than
the Reading Writing and arithmetic that
you'll learn in fifth grade
education is about how we're brought up
it's about how we view the world I was
thinking about this the other day
because I have friends and relatives who
are a bit neurotic and they worry a lot
about death
but they never think about death they
never they don't really take death
seriously but they worry about dying
and I was thinking about myself and it's
easy for me to say I'm a relatively
healthy guy and a sunshine in my life
but I think about death all the time
but I almost never worry about death
how is that well I think about death all
the time because I'm Christian and so I
think about okay have I committed a sin
am I in a state of grace do I need to go
to confession what am I going to have a
good death I mean this was something
that
Christians for the vast majority of our
civilizations history they would think
about this sort of thing am I prepared
to meet my maker because death comes
like a thief in the night you never know
if you're going to go okay so you think
about death a lot but then if you
prepare for death you're not worried
about death I think okay I don't think I
turned to worm food I hope I don't go to
hell I think I'm preparing myself for
for the end of the story
okay good whereas if you ignore death if
you try to put it out of your mind
you're still going to have that nagging
sense of your mortality that's part of
the human condition and so paradoxically
you're going to be much much more
worried about it the more you try to put
it out of the Mind the more you're going
to be worried about it then it that all
of that got me thinking
this is our real education this is the
real kind of education that guides our
society it's not just the Reading
Writing and arithmetic it's not just the
facts about which wars were won by which
generals the real basis of our education
is
who do we think we are where do we think
we're going what do we think we're made
for what do we think good is what do we
think we're all doing here together
that's the really subtle stuff of our
education that's going to make or break
a civilization
where are we what are we for and for
Jane Fonda her understanding of evil and
good and progress and politics and all
of that it is informed by things that
are false and ugly and and wicked
and that's going to drive a civilization
crazy boy that was a great clip make
sure you ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel we'll
see you next time